Hallo und willkommen an alle, dies ist der
aktive Inferenz-Gaststream 28.1, es ist der
14. Oktober 2022.
Heute werden wir die
Neukonzeption der Rationalität von
Giovanni Rolla hören und diskutieren, also Giovanni, vielen Dank
für Ihre Teilnahme und wir
freuen uns sehr auf diese Präsentation und
Diskussion
danke danke dann es war mir eine Freude,
Ihre Einladung vor ein paar
Monaten zu erhalten und ich freue mich sehr, hier
zu sein, um diese Gelegenheit zu haben, meine Arbeit zu besprechen
Papier, das ich vor ein paar Jahren geschrieben habe,
und ähm, als wir hinter der Bühne sprachen,
habe ich meine Meinung ein paar
Mal geändert und ich werde das
während der Präsentation deutlich machen, seit
ich dieses Papier veröffentlicht habe, aber es ist mir eine
Freude  trotzdem die Chance
zu haben, dieses Video hier zu präsentieren und
es mit der Welt zu teilen, also bin ich sehr
glücklich,
äh, also werden wir darüber sprechen, die
Rationalität neu zu begreifen, und das ist die
Reiseroute  Ich habe darüber nachgedacht
, es Ihnen vorzustellen, also werde ich zuerst
über Rationalität und
inhaltslose Kognition sprechen, dann werde ich
meine Ansicht präsentieren, die ich radikal
inaktive Rationalität und
Sicherheitswörter über Entscheidungsfreiheit und kompetente Interaktion
und Argumentation und Rationalität genannt habe, die
mit einem Paar eng verbunden sind  von Einwänden, der
erste ist, dass
alles, was ich hier präsentiere, ein wahrer
Liberaler ist, in einer übermäßig liberalen Weise, es
umfasst zu viel, und der zweite
Einwand, von dem ich denke,
dass er Sie am meisten interessieren wird, ist, ob
er wirkungskompatibel ist  mit prädiktivem
Prozess in unserer prädiktiven Codierung, die
sich natürlich in der Einrichtung in der
Nähe der beiden Autos befindet,
um aktiven Einfluss zu nehmen,
also
hier ist das Entschuldigung,
meine ersten Gedanken zu diesem Thema
sind traditionell sehr
äh orthodox  Sicht auf Rationalität haben
äh geht meines Wissens nach
davon aus, dass
Rationalität in ihrer Argumentation
das für inst  ance Ich glaube, dass B in einer
Handlung a rational ist, wenn und nur wenn
es die Argumentation gibt, die
die Bure so untermauert, und natürlich ist es einfach
keine Argumentation, die Argumentationsfrage
muss mit bestimmten bestimmten
formalen Maßstäben wie äh klassische
Logik oder Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung oder erworben werden
Heuristiken, die gemäß diesem traditionellen Film so rational glauben und handeln,
erfordern die Erfüllung bestimmter formaler Standards,
und dies scheint mir, wie gesagt,
weitgehend eine Annahme darüber zu sein, was es
bedeutet, rational zu sein, wenn es darum geht,
Rationalität in Bezug auf Argumentation zu definieren,
also wenn Rationalität Argumentation erfordert
und  Wenn Argumentation die Bewertung
von Überzeugungen anhand bestimmter formaler
Maßstäbe beinhaltet, dann impliziert Rationalität einen
Inhalt für die Erkenntnis,
wobei der Inhalt meiner Meinung nach minimale
Genauigkeitsbedingungen aufweist, die in
der Lage sind,
richtig oder falsch zu sein, oder in oder in einem
gewichtigeren Begriff, der wahr oder falsch ist
Die Idee dabei ist, dass Rationalität
zwangsläufig Inhalte beinhaltet, die
Überzeugungen beinhalten  Argumentation und der Vergleich oder
Entschuldigung
, jetzt
ein Software-Update zu aktualisieren. Es tut mir leid, da war
ein Popup in meinem Fenster hier drüben, also
ähm
, das wäre meiner Meinung nach die Standardansicht
von Rationalität
und
wenn es so ist, dass Rationalität notwendigerweise
beinhaltet  Inhalt Es passt gut
zum klassischen Kognitivismus oder zum
Kognitivismus im Allgemeinen,
was die Ansicht ist, dass die Kombination
notwendigerweise
zumindest für einige
Kognitivisten
einen
repräsentationalen Inhalt beinhaltet
Genauigkeitsbedingungen,
aber diese klassische Sichtweise ist nicht so gut,
sie passt nicht so gut zu
radikal inaktiver und verkörperter
Kognition,
die ich hier bin, ähm, denke nicht
speziell an Radikalismus und Aktivismus von
Goodwin Maine in den letzten Büchern, aber ich
denke, es fordert auch andere heraus  Ansichten
, die nicht als radikal und
aktiv präsentiert werden, aber natürlich teilen sie einige
Kernaspekte mit radikal und aktiv  sm
wir könnten sie äh radikal verkörperte
Ansichten von Kognitionen nennen, wie
ähm mit den Ansichten von Ezekiel
Powell oder Berman
Sensory Model Life haben Sie auch
Gallaghers Vielfalt des Inaktivismus in seinem
Buch von 2017 und auch die Ich meine die Ansicht
von Tony Kimero in seinem  2009 Buch über
ökologische Psychologie und dynamische
Systeme haben sie alle gemeinsame Mieter
und hier bin ich, ich weiß, dass dies sehr
kontrovers ist, aber ich behandle diese
Ansichten als radikal verkörperte Ansichten der
Kognition und konzentriere mich jedoch speziell
auf radikale und aktive Ansichten des
Kochens
Sie alle sagen, dass die Anerkennung nicht gegenständlich ist,
was in
gewisser Weise bedeutet, dass wir an grundlegende
inhaltslose Formen der Erkenntnis denken können
oder eine inhaltslose Ebene der grundlegenden Ebene der
Anerkennung,
die durch die aktive
Erkundung der eigenen Umwelt und
jenseits von Radikalismus und Aktivismus entsteht  Was wir
meinen,
das könnte sein, dass diese Idee
in Bezug auf die Beherrschung von sensomotorischen Engagements ausgezahlt werden könnte,
eine Frage des Wissens  - wie
das Wissen, wie man sich mit seiner
Umgebung auseinandersetzt, anstatt zu wissen, dass die
Dinge so und so um einen herum sind, also
ist das sehr klar, was die Paulo und
Kollegen und äh Kimero zum Beispiel
in ihren Büchern tun, äh radikal und Aktivismus
hat eine gewisse Tendenz zur Verzerrung  Sinnesmodell-
Eingriffe Sinnesmodell-Schemata
usw.
und ähm,
aber die jüngsten Entwicklungen haben, glaube ich,
eingearbeitet, dass dies die
Verwendung des Kerns dieser Idee ist,
also wenn wir radikal verkörperte Ansichten
von Grübeln oder Radikal und Aktivismus
und den klassischen Treibstoff kombinieren  Rationalität,
was wir haben, ist etwas, das Angle
wie folgt beschrieben hat.
Ein Aktivismus ist die Ansicht, dass
Erkenntnis auf einem gebetsrationalen
Verständnis der Welt beruht, das
auf der sensomotorischen Erfassung realer
Lebenssituationen basiert,
und er erklärt diese äh diese Idee von
Vor-  rationales Verstehen
by
um
by by the die Ideen von Melopentin
Heidegger, wonach der Bezug
zur Welt nur eins sein kann, wurzelnd in
p  Inaktives Handeln beim Schauspielen und
Praktizieren wird durch
den Körper vermittelt. Was hier also implizit zu sein scheint,
ist, dass Rationalität im Gegensatz zu Schauspiel und Praxis
nicht
wirklich etwas ist, das sich nicht auf einer sehr
grundlegenden Ebene der Kombination befindet. Dies
geschah also, als wir wir
Machen Sie Platz für eine grundlegende Erkenntnisebene
, die in Aktivität und Praxis verwurzelt ist, und
trennen Sie sie von höheren
Kombinationsebenen, die normalerweise der
Ort des glücklichen Klassikers der Rationalität sind,
so dass
die Idee zusammenfassend diese
umstrittene Erkenntnis oder grundlegende Erkenntnis ist
, die durch Sinneswahrnehmung entsteht  Motorische
Engagements sind nicht rational,
also sensorische moderne Engagements, wie auch immer
Tugenden in produktiver Weise sein können, können nicht
vom Standpunkt der Rationalität bewertet werden,
nur Inhalt für Kognition
, Kombination auf hoher Ebene kann rationale
Definition sein, die sich
beispielsweise in Überzeugungen ausdrückt, und seit kurzem
und gut, das ist etwas  das habe
ich auf dem Papier nicht angesprochen, aber es
war meine implizite Motivation, d  Mit
diesem Thema
als jemand, der aus der Philosophie
des Geistes kommt, ist die Idee des Mythos der
gegebenen zumindest eine Version davon,
so schien es mir damals, und ähm, ich wurde
von einem Rezensenten zu Recht davon überzeugt,
das Thema nicht zu berühren
In meiner anfänglichen Präsentation war es sehr verworren,
aber es scheint mir, dass, wenn wir
grundlegendes Erkennen von rationalem Denken
und Handeln trennen und wir nicht auf
den
Brunnen zeigen, es keine, ich meine, Schnittmenge
zwischen diesen beiden Ebenen gibt, es scheint so
radikal und aktivistisch zu sein und  Äh ähnliche
Ansichten würden dem Mythos
der von Sellers und
Moderationen von McDowell als Problem gegebenen Unpopularität für
gebieterische Bereiche meines Geistes verschrieben,
also scheint es, dass dies meiner Meinung nach
[Musik]
ein philosophisch interessantes Problem ist,
aber es ist nicht etwas, das ist  äh, an der
Spitze des Papiers war es meine
implizite Motivation hier zu erklären,
wie wir die inhaltslose oder
grundlegende Ebene der Erkenntnis durch sensorische
moderne Auseinandersetzungen mit Ratio kombinieren können  Natürlich, wenn
Sie nicht können, scheint es, dass es eine Art Gegebenheit gibt
, die in unserem Bild des Geistes nicht vollständig erklärt
wird, also
wollte ich das. Ich möchte immer noch versuchen,
diese Intuition klarer zu erforschen, aber ich habe es
getan
Ich habe das nicht angesprochen, aber ich denke, es gibt etwas in der
Richtung, warum ich heute zeigen werde, dass
ich denke, es ist eine Möglichkeit,
diese Anschuldigung
, dem Mythos des Gegebenen verpflichtet zu sein,
also wie können wir Rationalität neu begreifen,
meine ich  Ich denke, um dieses
Problem zu vermeiden und die Idee zu vermeiden, dass wir
zwei Ebenen haben, die vollständig
voneinander getrennt sind, wo eine die Höhere
der Ort der klassischen Rationalität ist und was
sonst noch darunter ist, ist es nicht rational. Ich
denke, die Idee ist, die
Rationalität abzulehnen es  muss definiert werden oder es
beinhaltet notwendigerweise Argumentation
muss nicht noch konzipiert werden, aber
dann besteht die Herausforderung darin, einen
positiven
Vorschlag zu unterbreiten, was Rationalität ist, wenn nicht
Argumentation, und hier ist Susan H  Urley in einem Artikel
, von dem ich weiß, dass er der einzige ist
, der sich
mit diesem Thema befasst, und ich glaube, sie war
damals übrigens auch besorgt über den Mythos des Gegebenen, und er ist ein
langes Zitat von hier, als ich
las, dass es Rationalität ist  könnte
aus einem komplexen System der
zentralisierten Hierarchie Beziehungen von
Hemmung, Erleichterung und Koordination
zwischen verschiedenen horizontalen Schichten entstehen,
von denen jede dynamisch und
umweltsituiert Rationalität in
horizontalen oder modularen Begriffen neu gedacht wird, äh, ich weiß nicht
, ob sie diese
Terminologie verwenden muss, aber  Jedenfalls hat sie
sich für diesen Ausdruck entschieden, es hängt nachhaltig
mit der Umwelt zusammen, es hängt
nicht nur von internen Verfahren ab,
die zwischen Eingabe und Ausgabe wie
Inhalten vermitteln, entweder für den Organismus als
Ganzes oder für ein vertikal begrenztes
zentrales kognitives Modul, sondern es
hängt davon ab  komplexe Beziehungen zwischen
dedizierten Welten, an denen Schichten beteiligt sind,
die bestimmte Aspekte des n überwachen und darauf reagieren
natürlichen und sozialen Umfelds
und des neuronalen Netzwerks und reduzieren
ihr Feedback aus ihren Antworten. Dies ist
meines Wissens der früheste Fall von
jemandem, der auf eine Weise an dem inaktiven Ansatz arbeitet, der
offensichtlich eher
mit der Arbeit von
avano in Verbindung gebracht wird, der auch ein Aktivist ist, aber
in einem anderen Ansatz als Radikal und
Aktivismus, und hier ist das früheste
und meines Wissens, bevor ich dieses Papier schrieb,
dass der
klarste Vorschlag der Rationalität
in den einheimischen Begriffen neu konzipiert wurde, aber es ist
nicht etwas, das
nach ihrer Veröffentlichung an Bedeutung gewonnen hat  Meines Wissens nach
habe ich seitdem nicht viel gesehen
und zusammenfassend ist die Idee, dass
wir den erklärenden Fokus ändern müssen,
dass Rationalität nicht ausschließlich
als Inhalt gedacht wird, der
Kapazität beinhaltet. In diesem Vorschlag wird er angesiedelt
oder in erweiterte Welten eingebunden
und ob es radikal verkörpert ist,
hängt von der körperlichen Morphologie und Aktion ab
und davon, wie der Organismus positioniert ist und
handelt  Da in dieser Umgebung die
Idee minimal tot sein wird, ist das, was ich als
radikal inaktive Rationalität
bezeichne, äh, in einer sehr
losen Definition so weit, dass eine Asiatin
rational handelt, insofern der
Mensch eine kompetente Interaktion mit
ihrer Umgebung aufrechterhält, die ihre
kognitiven Fähigkeiten koordiniert  je nach
Umgebungsbedingungen von Zwängen
und festen Stationen und natürlich
erfordert dies manchmal die Anpassung an
unvorhergesehene Umstände, denn dies ist die
Kernintuition,
und es ist interessant, diese
Idee der radikalen und aktiven Rationalität
mit einer anderen von Susan Hurleys Ideen in
einem Text von 2003 zu vergleichen  Sie sagt
Gründe für das Handeln, dass sie argumentiert,
dass Gründe für das Handeln kontextgebunden sein könnten,
wo sie gegen
Gareth Evans Allgemeingültigkeitsbeschränkung argumentiert,
und dies ist die Verteidigung der Idee von
Inseln praktischer Rationalität,
also behandelt sie Rationalität immer noch als
etwas, das sich bezieht
hier zu argumentieren, aber diese Art der
Argumentation ist gebunden  d durch den praktischen
Kontext, also ist dies eine sehr progressive
Sichtweise im Vergleich zu der traditionellen
Sichtweise, über die ich am Anfang gesprochen habe,
aber immer noch konservativer als das, was
ich hier zu entwickeln versuche,
so dass eine andere Sache, von der ich denke, dass sie im Vordergrund stehen muss
Vorschlag
ist, dass Rationalität Handlungsfähigkeit und Autonomie impliziert,
weil etwas oder nur
etwas, das ein Organismus tut
, als rational richtig bezeichnet werden kann,
also verwenden Sie diese Ideen aus dem
autonomen und aktivistischen Lager und aus
der Theorie, wie Spieler
autonome Systeme sind, wie z  Ein Roomba
kann nicht rational sein, weil er kein
Agent ist, er ist nicht der Urheber seines eigenen
Verhaltens, er wurde von externen
Agenten entworfen, um auf eine bestimmte Weise zu funktionieren, also ist
er genau genommen keine Nation,
also würde ich dort die Grenze ziehen, wo
gut  Es macht keinen Sinn,
beispielsweise einem Roomba Rationalität zuzuschreiben,
und
dafür verwende
ich die Begriffe Autonomie und
Adaptivität, die DiPaolo und andere
haben  Auch das jüngste Buchbild The Four Sensory
Model Life und das berühmte
Paper from the Bowl aus dem Jahr 2005, in dem er
über die Adaptivität spricht
, seine sehr allgemeinen Einschränkungen dessen,
was es bedeutet, Russe zu sein, so zu setzen,
dass autonome Systeme dabei
als prekäre Netzwerke aufgefasst werden
prekäres Netzwerk von Prozessen, da
Organisation und physische
Grenzen vom System selbst erzeugt werden, hält das
System ständig seine eigenen äh
Lebensfähigkeitsbedingungen aufrecht,
was als Sinnstiftung bekannt ist, wo das
System äh Umweltbedingungen erkundet
, die
für seine äh Selbsterhaltung günstig sind, und
vermeidet diejenigen, die ihm abträglich sind,
so verstehe ich
das ganz allgemein, dass
sie ein rationales Wesen emotional einschränken,
dass es ein autonomes System sein muss,
und das Interessante hier ist, dass
das Konzept der Adaptivität, das Paulo aber hat
Hervorzuheben ist die Fähigkeit eines
Organismus, seinen Zustand der Selbstproduktion zu verbessern
h interne
strukturelle Veränderungen,
also die Überwachung und
Regulierung interner Veränderungen
, um die beste verfügbare Vorgehensweise auszuwählen.
Ich denke, es ist ein weiteres
interessantes Konzept, darüber nachzudenken,
diese Idee einer radikal
inaktiven Vorstellung von Rationalität einzubeziehen
ist nicht unbedingt auf
Argumentation und Inhalt festgelegt,
so dass Handlungsfähigkeit durch die
Ausübung von situierten Fähigkeiten realisiert wird,
die Veränderungen innerhalb des Organismus in
Übereinstimmung mit
Umweltbedingungen und Unterstationen fördern,
was bedeutet, dass es ein Maß ist, wie gut sich ein Organismus
anpasst, um kompetent
mit seiner Umwelt umzugehen  oder
ein Hinweis auf seine Rationalität
Je rationaler ein Organismus ist, desto
besser ist er geeignet, mit seiner Umwelt umzugehen,
und wir haben die
Umstände vorhergesehen,
und dabei verstärkt der Organismus den
kontinuierlichen Austausch zwischen sich
und der Umwelt,
der für sein Überleben entscheidend ist, und  es
ist eine sehr
eingebürgerte Denkweise der
Rationalität  ist hauptsächlich die Fähigkeit,
Veränderungen zum Überleben zu verbessern.
Dies ist
die Gesamtidee hier.
Wie ich bereits sagte, was ist mit Argumentation?
Ich möchte Rationalität nicht
unbedingt mit Argumentation begehen, und darum geht
es bei radikal inaktiver Rationalität,
aber ich  Ich möchte
Argumentation nicht als frühere rationale
Kombination ausschließen, also sage ich, dass
es nicht durch Argumentation definiert ist, aber es ist
nicht, äh, es schließt Argumentation nicht aus
Eines, das unserem
Wissen exklusiv für Menschen ist,
aber es ist nicht das definierende Merkmal der
Rationalität,
also um diese Idee zu erklären,
erinnere ich mich, wie Hutu und
Saturn zwischen den Artikeln im neuesten
Buch von Utani das erklären
Entstehung hoher Anerkennung Die Idee ist,
dass die Fähigkeit, sich mit Inhalten für die
Kognition zu beschäftigen, letztendlich davon abhängt, dass sie
sozial kulturell eingebettet sind,
wo die inhaltsvolle Kognition aus der Gesellschaft hervorgegangen ist
Wenn
ein Individuum an sozialkulturellen Praktiken teilnimmt,
akzeptiert es ältere kognitive
Fähigkeiten, um mit Symbolen umzugehen, und dadurch wird
es
natürlich in einem langen Prozess der
Enkulturation fähig, sich auf
symbolische Koordination einzulassen, die nicht
intern ist  Repräsentationsspezifisch, weil
es öffentlich verfügbar ist, handelt es sich nicht um mentale
Repräsentationen im traditionellen Sinne,
sondern es hat die Merkmale symbolischer
Kognition ohne die Bindung an
interne Repräsentationen oder mentale
Repräsentationen
Organismus ist in äh ist ist
das kompetente Verhalten eines Organismus
in seiner Umgebung, es hängt von der
Koordination verkörperter Fähigkeiten ab,
während Argumentieren, wenn alles gut geht,
natürlich als Inhalt
für Rationalität verstanden wird, für meine spezifische Art der
Rationalität ist Argumentieren das kompetente
Verhalten eines  Organismus in einem sozialen
kulturellen en  Umwelt,
die natürlich ein spezifischerer Aspekt unserer
Umwelt ist, und es hängt von
der Koordination solcher kulturell
bedingten oder inhaltsbezogenen Fähigkeiten ab,
die in der menschlichen phylogenetischen Skala neuer sind,
so gut, dass dies die größte
Idee ist  Ich denke,
äh, das ist der positive Teil, und hier sind
die Einwände, über die ich zuerst sprechen wollte
, nämlich dass es eine sehr liberale
Sichtweise ist, es ist sehr
äh, es ist gut, es umfasst zu viel
, würde man sagen, denn wenn rationales
Handeln auf die Koordination hinausläuft
kognitiver Fähigkeiten dann ist Rationalität
etwas Allmähliches für einen Organismus
, der mehr oder weniger kompetent in seinen
Umweltinteraktionen sein könnte,
und die Ablehnung geht mit
radikal inaktiver Rationalität einher. Viele
Organismen erreichen und behalten ein
adaptives Verhalten in der Nische mit
unterschiedlichem Erfolg bei, zu dem ich
bin uh gut jemand könnte rational
und aktiv radikale und aktive
Rationalitäten zu Liberalen singen und das ist  Ein
Einwand, den ich mir persönlich angehört habe
und den ich so hart behielt, weil ich
es für eine sehr gute Art
und Weise halte, es auszudrücken, sogar Nägel sind rational auf
dieser Ansicht und dazu muss ich sagen,
dass ich bereit bin, sie zu kaufen  der Geldbeutel
naja ja er ist liberaler als
traditionelle Ansichten natürlich
soll das so sein aber ich denke nicht dass
das per se ein Problem ist was meiner Meinung nach
das positive daran ist dass
es einen graduellen Unterschied zwischen den
Menschen bewahrt  viel rationaler als andere
Tiere, einfach weil wir in der Lage sind
, eine Vielzahl von Aktionen in einer
Vielzahl dynamischer Umstände
auszuführen, die weit über alle anderen Tiere
hinausgehen, die wir kennen,
also um auf das Beispiel dieses
Nagels zurückzukommen dieser Nagel kann  ein paar komplexe
Aktionen ausführen, sich von einem Punkt zum
anderen bewegen können, nach Nahrung und Unterschlupf suchen können
und so weiter, aber sie haben
eine begrenzte Anzahl von Fähigkeiten, wenn
Sie diesen Nagel mit dem Süden umgeben,
zum Beispiel ist er dazu verdammt, zu sterben
Die Erwiderung und die Menschen
andererseits sind viel anpassungsfähiger und in der
Lage, dynamisch mit vielen
unvorhergesehenen Umständen umzugehen, also ähm
, meine Antwort auf diesen Einwand lautet:
Ja,
ähm, es ist sehr liberal, aber das ist
nicht das Problem, das Problem wäre, wenn das so wäre
Es wäre, wenn es Raum für einen
graduellen Unterschied zwischen dem Umgang von Tieren
mit ihrer
Umgebung und dem anderen
Objekteinwand gäbe, von dem ich denke, dass es
der eine ist, der Sie am meisten interessiert, dann
wissen Sie, dass die 12 Vorhersageverarbeitung ist
scheint Schlussfolgerungen und Inhalte zu implizieren
,
äh, aber zuerst muss ich Sie und
die Zuschauer warnen, dass
zu der Zeit, als ich diese äh, dieses Papier schrieb,
viel optimistischer war, was diese
Möglichkeit der Kombination von Aktivismus und
prädiktiver Codierung oder prädiktiver
Verarbeitung und äh anbelangt  Ich denke, es gibt
hier wichtige Punkte, aber es gibt dieses
kürzlich erschienene Papier von Olu und Evan Thompson
und Randy Beer, in dem sie äh, sie
liefern eine kritische Bewertung von äh
Das sind die Versuche, hauptsächlich
das Prinzip der freien Energie und
um
inaktive und
autobiografische Theorien zu kombinieren, also bin ich jetzt
hauptsächlich von den Argumenten überzeugt, aber ich
denke, es gibt
hier dennoch einige interessante Vergleichspunkte,
also der Vorhersageprozess in unserem Vorhersagecode
und ähm  Zeit, als ich schrieb,
und bis heute ist es der letzte Schrei in
den Kognitionswissenschaften. Ich denke, man kann
sagen, dass es so klang, als ob Süßigkeiten zu
einem der wichtigsten Paradigmen da draußen geworden sind, also ist
es interessant zu sehen, ob es
gut zu dem passt, was ich finde  Ich spreche
und in diesen Viewern weißt du, dass
Wettbewerb als ein Prozess
der Fehlerminimierung verstanden wird, der in
engen Hierarchien bidirektional abläuft,
also
hast du die Generierung interner
Modelle für die Aktivität niedrigerer Schichten
, die die distalen Ursachen von
finsteren Reizen antizipieren, was ein ist  Top-Down-
Verfahren und die Minimierung der
Diskrepanz zwischen Prädiktion und
aktuellem Reizsignal durch
um die Besetzung von Priors, die  ist ein
Ende des Prozesses,
also ist hier natürlich aktive Schlussfolgerung,
die zum Beispiel in
einem informellen Sie kennen formalen Begriff von
Clark verstanden wird, dass ein Organismus seine Sensoren
auf eine Weise bewegt, die darauf hinausläuft, aktiv in unserer Generation zu suchen und
die sensorischen
Konsequenzen zu erzeugen, die sie sind  Ihre
Gehirne erwarten, dass
dies eine Möglichkeit ist,
sehr formale Begriffe der aktiven Beeinflussung zu verstehen, aber ich
denke, es erledigt die Arbeit,
so dass das Gehirn auf die erwartete
Quelle der empfangenen Reize schlussfolgert, wenn
es scheint, dass es ein
Problem mit dem gibt, was ich bin  Wenn wir darüber sprechen,
so sagt die Lesart von Predictive
Processing, die das
Produkt-Bias- und Inferenzrecht verwendet,
zum Beispiel, dass der Prozess der
Perceptionistas von einem
rationalen, breiteren Biasing-Prozess der
Vermehrung und Kontext-Top-Down-
Effekten trennbar ist, von denen ich fühlte, dass jede
Zwischenebene von  Als ich das verarbeitet habe, ist mir
aufgefallen, dass Clark auch die
ganze Zeit über Rationalität spricht,
aber es ist eine  Eine schlussfolgernde Art von
Rationalität
und allgegenwärtiger Influencer-Argumentation scheint
einen durchdringenden Inhalt zu implizieren,
und dann scheint die prädiktive Verarbeitung
mit radikal inaktiver Rationalität unvereinbar zu sein,
aber es gibt äh zu der Zeit, als es sie
gab, und ich denke, wir können immer noch argumentieren, dass
es kein Nein gibt
-Hämorrhoiden und Lektüre von
Vorhersageverarbeitung,
die zum Beispiel einen ersten Schritt verwendet,
wäre ein deflationärer
Vorhersagesinn, der in einem
kurzen Papier aus dem Jahr 2013 verstanden wurde, aber viertens, wo
die Werte von zwei oder mehr Variablen
kovariieren oder so zuverlässig sind
Der Wert 1 ermöglicht es dem Beobachter, auf
den Wert eines anderen zu schließen, und
hier geschieht die Schlussfolgerung auf der
Ebene der Beobachtung, nicht auf einer fernen
Variablen, die auf den Wert einer
anderen schlussfolgert, also wäre die Idee,
dass der Inhalt meiner Meinung nach im Auge von liegt  der
Betrachter die Person, die interpretiert, wie
die Auswahl der Zensur, die wir setzen,
ungefähre interne Vorhersagen hier
in t verstanden  Der inflationäre Sinn
kann es mit schlussfolgernden und voreingenommenen
Begriffen beschreiben, so sehe ich zum Beispiel
die Idee über 4 000 von
Bruno, die, wenn ich mich nicht irre,
so etwas wie das Gehirn ist
kein Wissenschaftler und das Argument ist in  Diese
allgemeine Richtung
, die wir projizieren, wie
Wissenschaftler die Gehirnaktivität als ein
Merkmal des Gehirns selbst interpretieren, als ob
es diesen
robusteren oder gewichtigeren Sinn vorhersagen und ableiten würde,
also versuche ich hier zu sagen, dass
aktive Schlussfolgerung dann doppelt verwendet wird  und
sagen Sie doppelt, vergessen Sie den Namen davon auf
Englisch. Entschuldigung,
ähm, es ist nicht der wörtliche Sinn der
Schlussfolgerung hier nach radikal
inaktiver
äh Rationalität ist, dass der Agent unbewaffnet für die
Effizienz von co-orientiertem Verhalten
auf bestimmte Weise handeln muss,
um für ihn zu sorgen  Seine oder ihre Zustände kommen
effizienter und kostengünstiger zum Tragen.
Dies impliziert nicht die umstrittenere
Behauptung, dass die generativen Modelle
selbst prädiktive Schlussfolgerungen anzeigen und ausführen
Es ist eine sehr
deflationäre Lesart der
Vorhersageverarbeitung, um diese
Kombination mit radikaler und aktiver
Rationalität zu versehen,
und hier ist ein Auftakt in einem Artikel aus dem Jahr
nach Modell, aus dem nicht folgt, dass ein
Organismus ein internes
Repräsentationsmodell seiner Nische
hat es  Ist dieses Modell die
kognitive Arbeit, wenn Sie möchten, stattdessen ist ein
Organismus ein Modell, das die kausalen
und statistischen Regelmäßigkeiten in
einer Umgebung widerspiegelt, die einen
Phänotyp widerspiegelt, der ein Modell ist,
und nun,
das bezieht sich auf etwas, das kürzlich,
äh, meine Kollegin notifica und ich
Ich habe über die Idee gesprochen, wie Organismen
eine Welt hervorbringen, gemäß einem
Aktivismus, der der Idee entspricht, dass der Organismus
und die Umwelt
historisch als determiniert bezeichnet werden, sodass dies
auf flussgenetischer Ebene
durch die Idee der Nischenkonstruktion erklärt werden könnte
die Idee, dass einmal  Ein
Organismus ist in seiner Umgebung aktiv und
fördert Veränderungen, die stabil
genug sind  Sie können von ihren Nachkommen vererbt werden
und diese Veränderungen liefern neue
evolutionäre Pressdrucke
, die ihren evolutionären Weg leiten.
Eine ähnliche Idee wurde auch von
anderen Beschreibungen untersucht, diesmal in Bezug auf
Nischenkonstruktion
und ökologische Psychologie,
also ist meine Antwort auf diesen Einwand
dass rationales Handeln bedeutet,
eine kompetente Auseinandersetzung mit der
Umwelt durch Vorhersagen
und deren Minimierung zu erreichen. Ich bin bereit zu
akzeptieren, dass Charakterisierung, aber
rationale und breitere voreingenommene Prozesse
keinen Erkenntnisinhalt implizieren
müssen,
wenn wir das im Flash verstehen  Keine
sinnvolle Vorhersage und ihre Minimierung
beinhalten die Auswahl von Eingaben und die
Koordination einer Interfähigkeit in Weltbeteiligungsweisen,
was
genau der Hauptanspruch einer radikalen und
aktiven Persönlichkeit ist, daher denke ich,
insofern, dass die Vorhersageverarbeitung kein
äh ein Feind wäre  als eine
Lüge dieser Idee statt äh
Ankunft, sondern von c  Natürlich gibt es noch andere
Kompatibilitätsprobleme, die ich
hier nicht angesprochen habe, aber das ist alles, woran
ich für heute gedacht
habe  Schreiben Sie alle Fragen Ich werde
meine Notizen sammeln und lass uns mit der Diskussion beginnen
Okay,
gut zuerst noch einmal vielen Dank für das
Gespräch
Wie wäre es mit einem kleinen Kontext darüber, wie Sie dazu
kamen, diese Fragen in
Ihrer aktuellen Position zu stellen, und wie sich Ihre
Interessen in diesem Bereich entwickelt
haben?  so viele interessante Ideen und
ich wollte nur mehr darüber erfahren, wie
Sie zu diesem Framing gekommen sind und Ihren Standpunkt geschärft haben
Ich glaube, ich habe meine Dissertation geschrieben,
es war vielleicht 2007 oder so, und ähm, ich
habe für die Idee argumentiert, dass
Rationalität etwas sein muss, an dem
letztendlich die Welt beteiligt ist  Es gibt eine
Tendenz, gut zu denken, sogar unter, wie
ich sagte, wie ich Ihnen gezeigt habe, unter uh in
verkörperten Perioden mit Menschen von gewissem,
es muss im Wesentlichen Welt sein,
die wie Handeln und Üben
und so weiter
und Wahrnehmung natürlich beinhaltet, aber Rationalität
bleibt  so etwas wie ein naturalisierbarer
Begriff etwas, das
nicht auf die Ebene des das heruntergebracht werden kann, es
konnte nicht auf eine Weise herunterskaliert werden
wie eine Wahrnehmung, die
durch eine bestimmte dynamische Auseinandersetzung erklärt werden könnte und so
weiter, so
dachte ich zu der Zeit gut
Vielleicht ist dies
ein Knieproblem, weil
in
anderen Kontexten angenommen wird, dass
jede Wahrnehmung, wenn sie nicht so artikuliert ist, dass
sie eine
bestimmte Übereinstimmung mit der professionellen
Kombination bietet, eine gegebene Wahrnehmung ist,
und dies ist der Mythos der gegebenen
Dimension  am Anfang und ich dachte
, das ist vielleicht so
etwas wie ein Mythos des
gegebenen Arbeitens hier an einer aktiven
Erkenntnis, aber das ist es nicht, denke ich  Das ist
nicht fatal, weil wir prinzipiell nicht
argumentieren könnten, dass wir, anstatt
die Schrittwahrnehmung und
andere Grundformen von Kombinationen
mit Konzepten und dergleichen zu konstruieren, vielleicht
aus der anderen Richtung argumentieren könnten, versuchen,
die Rationalität auf ein nicht naturalisierteres
Niveau von
äh herunterzuskalieren
Das war also die Motivation und es war
sehr, es war ein langer Überprüfungsprozess, und ich
glaube, dass meine erste die erste
Version des Papiers der Betrachter sehr war. Ich
denke, sie lagen vollkommen richtig. Ich
habe den Vorschlag schließlich befürwortet, aber er
war sehr äh
sie  waren sehr hartnäckig, diesen Teil zu übernehmen
, und ich denke, es war besser,
weil es eine andere Literatur
ist, eine andere, äh, viele Referenzen,
die normalerweise nicht mit
Aktivismus und Körpererkennung in Verbindung stehen, und es war
sehr schwierig, das einfach auszudrücken  Es ist
in gleicher Weise wichtig, meine Argumente vorzubringen,
also ist es etwas, das ich gestrichen habe,
und ich habe nicht zu viel über
dieses System nachgedacht, aber ich denke, es ist etwas, das ich
gerne hätte  Um darauf zurückzukommen und
vielleicht hat das jemand in den letzten Jahren getan.
Ich bin mir nicht bewusst, dass ich
mich erinnern kann, aber
diese Beziehung zwischen einem Aktivismus, dem
Mythos der Gabe und dem, was es
zu sein schien, scheint sehr
offensichtlich zu sein  Ich denke also, es ist etwas, das
wir erforschen könnten, ich meine, äh, in der Lage sein sollten
, aber es gibt nichts,
was im Vordergrund des Papiers stand
,
aber ich hatte diese Idee, über
Rationalität in jedem Sinne
und gleichzeitig zu sprechen  Ich habe damals viel über ihn gelesen und
ihn aus philosophischer Sicht angerufen.
Natürlich bin ich, wie gesagt, nicht
sehr bewandert in den technischen
Details und den Formalitäten der Herangehensweise,
aber ich interessierte mich für die
philosophischen Konsequenzen dort und
dachte gut  Vielleicht gibt es hier etwas zum
Vergleichen, denn wie Clarks
Zitat zeigt
, kann man durchaus über Rationalität sprechen
, und äh, das wollte
ich entwickeln, aber nicht in einer kognitivistischen Sichtweise, aber nicht in einem
radikal verkörperten Film
Das ist der Hintergrund,
großartig, danke, könnten Sie vielleicht
beschreiben, was der Mythos des
Gegebenen ist, in welchem ​​Kontext dieser
Mythos entstand, und wohin wir gehen, nachdem wir
den Mythos des Gegebenen
angesprochen haben, weil ich es als ein Konzept gesehen habe  Sie haben
eingewoben, also worum ging es,
okay, also in der Mitte des
Gebens gibt es mehrere mögliche Gegebenheiten,
abhängig von Ihrem Geschmack
meiner Philosophie, aber am klassischsten in früheren
Bereichen des Geistes, nehmen Sie den
Inhalt der Wahrnehmung, der gegeben werden soll  Beten Sie
rational auf eine Weise, dass wir bestimmte
Eingaben haben, die gerade vom Verstand empfangen werden
, und der Verstand interpretiert sie so
für Rationalisten,
aber auf der anderen Seite wird rational
normalerweise als gegeben angesehen, äh rationale Intuition
, was bedeutet, dass es eine
gewisse Ebene der Erkenntnis gibt, die äh
unartikuliert ist.  ist gegeben oder wie manche
Leute davon sprechen, gegeben zu sein,
aber in gewisser Weise gibt es diese
Erkenntnisebene, die gegeben ist, und der Verstand muss
sie interpretieren, aber wenn sie auf
diese Weise gegeben ist, hat sie keinen Berührungspunkt, keine
äh Schnittmenge zwischen was auch immer
Was auch immer der Verstand tut und und diese grundlegende
Ebene der Beherrschung, also ist meine Idee,
den Vorwurf zu vermeiden
, dem Mythos des Gegebenen verpflichtet zu sein, aber auch dies
ist nicht etwas, das in der nativistischen Literatur explizit steht,
aber
es scheint etwas zu sein  Es ist möglich,
in dieser Art von Vergleich etwas zu entwickeln, aber
es liegt nicht daran, dass es
nicht klar ist, sondern
eine Möglichkeit, sie für die Givens zu lösen, um
zu sagen, dass Wahrnehmungsinhalte
bereits konzeptueller Natur sind,
wie beispielsweise Joe McDowell
Bedenkt, je mehr Sie wissen, eine
Wahrnehmung, äh, der Witz ist, Sie kommen mit
Untertiteln und interpretieren die Welt so,
wie Sie es tun, aber äh,
ich denke, dass die eine oder andere Weise darin besteht
, Sie zu entmystifizieren, eine Rationalität  und
die oberen Ebenen der Kombination versuchen und
versuchen, an sie zu denken, uh uh, in weniger
ähm Inhalt für die Analyse,
ohne sie festzulegen, also ist es streng
genommen mit einer Inhaltsebene, die
von den grundlegenden Ebenen der
Kombination getrennt ist, das ist eine Möglichkeit, die
ich mir vorstelle, und  Rationalität scheint das
einzige Schlüsselkonzept dafür zu sein, weil
normalerweise davon ausgegangen wird, dass alles etwas
ausschließlich Menschliches ist und etwas, das
mit dem Denken zusammenhängt, und wenn dem so ist
, kann Rationalität das Handeln nicht informieren,
und wenn das Handeln natürlich
inhaltslos ist  Also, wenn
Rationalität ein Sinn ist, der im Wesentlichen inhaltsreich ist und
Reaktion im Wesentlichen unbeschränkt für
inhaltslos, dann können Sie
diese
äh, das hat diese äh Schnittmenge
zwischen zwei Bereichen nicht gemacht, und das ist
etwas, das ich vermeiden wollte, aber wie ich
Ihnen sagte, es wurde so schwierig
Diese Ansichten in
ausreichend klarer und allgemeiner Weise auszudrücken ist,
dass ich auf Empfehlung unseres
Rezensenten das streiche und
ich mir noch Gedanken darüber mache  Aber nichts, ich
habe keine richtige
Argumentationslinie entwickelt, die
klarer damit umgeht, als ich es tun kann, wie ich es gerade getan habe.
Ganz allgemein
cool, einige Wörter, die Sie
mit Rationalität in Verbindung gebracht haben, waren Anpassungsfähigkeit
und auch Kompetenz
als die Beziehung von Rationalität und
Fitness
als biologische Funktion richtig ja ja
okay Ich ähm,
ich denke, es ist eine intrinsische
Beziehung, wirklich, ich denke, es ist
äh, wahrscheinlich die
offensichtlichste Folge rationalen Handelns
in einem bestimmten Ausmaß und wann  Wir sprechen
darüber, ob Rationalität ein Merkmal
von äh bestimmten Arten ist oder statt von
Individuen. Ich denke, Fitness ist eines
der Schlüsselkonzepte hier, um dies
als das Ergebnis dieser
äh rationalen Handlung zu betrachten
, obwohl ich nicht sage, dass ich es nicht tue
Stellen Sie es in diese Angelegenheiten in die Zeitung. Ich
denke, es ist möglich, es so zu denken
, Sie wissen, sehen Sie es nicht
als Einwand, an Rationalität zu denken,
aber es ist wieder sehr liberal,
und ich bin bereit, es zu tun  o Diese
Konsequenz muss auch jeder lebende
Organismus in gewisser Weise hinnehmen, wenn er, wenn er noch
nicht instinktiv geworden ist, so dass er in gewisser Weise
an seine Umgebung angepasst ist, so dass ich bereit bin
zu sehen, dass es ein
Mindestmaß an Rationalität beinhalten kann  Der Umgang mit
dem feindlichen, sich verändernden Umfeld,
aber gut, und es ist der Preis dafür, eine
sehr
äh,
liberale progressive Vorstellung von
Rationalitäten zu haben. Das ist eine Folge
davon. Ich glaube
, Sie haben also gesagt, dass Fitness eine
Folge von rationalem Verhalten ist
Wie können
wir Rationalität von außen erkennen,
außer nur zu sagen, dass die
Ameisenkolonie in dem Maße gedeiht, dass
sie rational ist, dass sie anpassungsfähig ist und eine
Agentur darstellt, und all das,
ähm, ist dies ein so deflationäres
Rationalitätskonzept, das alle existierenden
Dinge, Menschen und  Anderes wird lediglich
durch su beschrieben oder gibt es einige Ergebnisse, die wir verwenden können, um wie zum Beispiel ein rationales oder irrationales Verhalten von den lediglich durch su reflektierten Konsequenzen zu trennen  rvival and
Fitness
right well I Ich musste sehr sorgfältig darüber nachdenken,
weil ich
dieses Konzept nicht so trivialisieren möchte,
dass alles IPS oder
rational ist, weil es tatsächlich eine
Beziehung ist, aber ich lebe
denke, dass äh in bestimmten Fällen
könnte man äh die Nation identifizieren, dass
ich den Individuen gleich
komme, um Selbsterhaltung in dieser Nische, also so
auf der individuellen Ebene, insbesondere
okay, dies ist eine schlüssige bestimmte
Handlung
, die insofern irrational einordnen könnte, als sie  äh
sind schädlich für das Überleben, aber
äh auf der Ebene der Spezies ist es
schwieriger, auf diese Weise zu argumentieren, weil
diese Art von Verhalten oder Konsequenz identifiziert werden soll,
aber ich denke, dass, um
die Idee von rational nicht zu trivialisieren
und alles zu sagen, was ist
Das Leben ist ein faktorisierter Faktor, man müsste
diese Art von bestimmten Handlungen
identifizieren,
die einem Überleben schaden,
also im Fall der Ameisenkolonie
weiß ich es vielleicht nicht
Eindringlinge willkommen zu heißen wäre ein
Verhalten, das
dem
Überleben als solchem ​​abträglich wäre.
Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, ob
das eine unmögliche Art ist
, darüber nachzudenken
sorgfältig,
oh, sehr interessant, und Sie
haben diese Antwort und in die
Präsentation mehrere
verschachtelte Zeitskalen eingebracht, genau wie Eco Evo
Devo es aus einer eher biologischen
Perspektive betrachtet, und betrachten, wie die
Nischenkonstruktion die Lücke zwischen
langsameren phylogenetischen Prozessen und
schnelleren Entwicklungsprozessen überbrückt
ähm so  Wie verhält sich diese
eingebettete und multiskalige Betrachtung
zum
Inhaltskonzept?
Wird der Inhalt in einem Körper lokalisiert oder ist der Inhalt
auf Entitäten verteilt oder ist die
Rationalität auf Entitäten verteilt?
Wie würden wir überhaupt den Ort der Rationalität identifizieren und das?
beruft sich auch irgendwie auf das horizontale und modulare
Konzept aus dem Zitat, das Sie zur
Verfügung gestellt haben. Wie können wir also Hervorhebungen identifizieren?
räumliche zeitliche Skalen und Systeme von
Interesse
oh ah Ich weiß nicht Ich weiß nicht ob ich
das vollständig beantworten kann aber es scheint mir,
dass auf der Ebene von äh, wenn wir
über Inhalt sprechen, zum Beispiel Inhalt als
Genauigkeit  Bedingungen für symbolische
Gedanken Ich denke, zum Glück müssen wir
sagen, dass es nicht in einer einzelnen Person lokalisiert ist,
es wird öffentlich geteilt,
also kann man sagen, dass
eine Folge davon ist, dass es
möglich ist, an verschiedene
Denkmuster zu denken,
die Informationsseiten
waren  zu unterschiedlichen Zeiten usw. und Sie können
sehen, dass sie verschiedene Regeln für Inhaltsinformationen auf unterschiedlichen Ebenen entwickelt haben,
und ich denke, es ist
plausibel zu sagen, dass Inhalt
lokalisiert ist, dass die
äh, wie können Sie sagen, dass er die Menge teilt, von der
Sie die Einzelheiten kennen
Nur der Rationalität halber denke ich, dass
man
[Musik]
bestimmte Verhaltensweisen identifizieren
könnte, wenn es auf diese äh
diese Art von Beschreibung von äh Spin
tüchtig, tüchtige Interaktion und
Anpassung passt  Interaktion zwischen einem Organismus
und seiner Umgebung seine Nische, also
könnten wir hier wahrscheinlich unterschiedliche Antworten geben
als Rationalität und Inhalt Ich bin bereit
zu sagen, dass
Inhalt für die Organisation nicht
etwas ist, das im Kopf passiert,
etwas, das in gewisser Weise da draußen ist
die Menge anderer und das ist
etwas, was die Philosophie von mir
hat, zumindest seit den 60er Jahren haben die
Philosophen von mir
argumentiert, dass Inhalte extern
individuiert werden,
und ähm, ich denke, das ist eines
der Videos von  zum Beispiel Hillary Putnam
und Tyler Burge und andere, dass der
mentale Inhalt auf
Gemeinschaftsebene oder gesellschaftlicher Ebene individualisiert wird, aber
andererseits denken sie, dass
Rationalität im Prinzip
in bestimmten Verhaltensweisen individualisiert werden könnte, aber
es würde von den
Zielen und den Zielen des Einzelnen abhängen  die Nische, die es bewohnt und
so weiter usw.
Natürlich gibt es hier tatsächliche Variablen
, die auch wichtig sein könnten
, um das Verhalten zu identifizieren
Als rational oder nicht
okay,
ähm, gut, ein Satz, der mir wirklich in Erinnerung geblieben ist
, war „Know how not know that“,
vielleicht ein grundlegender Punkt in Ihrer Arbeit
und ein Fokus auf diese Aktion, also wollte ich nur
hören, wie Sie handeln und üben, während
Sie woben  sie hier heute, wie werden diese
begriffe angesprochen
und wie sieht es heute anders aus mit
der behandlung von handlung und praxis und
wissen das nicht, als sagen wir in
helmholtzee-tagen oder gar in uralten
oder in
weltwissenstraditionen also ok cool also die idee  Ich
denke,
ähm,
es gibt eine
Tendenz von einer sehr modernen Philosophie,
aber es war sehr einflussreich in der
ersten Welle der Kognitionswissenschaft,
Wahrnehmung
als Fähigkeit zu betrachten, die Umgebung zu kategorisieren
und eine Diskretion anzubieten  Beschreibung von
Umweltaspekten, also zum Beispiel
wahrzunehmen, dass äh das das das
das ich weiß das der Becher zu meiner Linken ist,
eine Frage des Wissens ist, dass es eine
Sache mit der Suche nach solchen Eigenschaften gibt
meine Linke und das ist eine Art von ähm, wissen,
dass eine Art propositionale Haltung
gegenüber der Welt, also
ähm, ich denke, das ist das
Interessante an einem Aktivismus und einer
ökologischen Psychologie sowie in dem
Maße, in dem sie an den amerikanischen
Pragmatismus von Anfang an erinnern  Das
Jahrhundert soll
Wahrnehmung nicht als eine Frage der
Kategorisierung dieser großartigen Eigenschaften in
der Welt betrachten, sondern als
Offenlegung von Handlungsmöglichkeiten,
und das ist etwas, das wir
erklären würden, wenn wir das in Begriffen von äh in epidemischen
Begriffen wie Wissen erklären würden.
Es geht nicht darum, zu wissen, dass die
Kurve zu meiner Linken ist, sondern zu wissen, wie
ich die Tasse greifen und damit tun kann, was ich will,
wenn ich eine Tasse
Kaffee trinken oder sie als Tasse verwenden möchte
Papierbeschwerer wird es andere
stille Eigenschaften haben, und das ist etwas, was
ich denke, obwohl es
ein Aktivismus und eine ökologische
Psychologie und andere verkörperte Sichtweisen der
Erkenntnis weitgehend
erfolgreich waren  Wenn ich diese Diskussion zu diesem
Punkt bringe, denke ich, dass Sie in den
traditionelleren Kognitionswissenschaften immer
noch die Idee haben, dass gut
Organismen wahrgenommen werden, indem
sie die Art und Weise beschreiben, wie die Umwelt
dies etwas ist, was meiner Meinung
nach traditionellere Lesarten der
prädiktiven Verarbeitung klar machen
wie in äh die Idee, dass Sie
auf die Quelle der Reize schließen und nicht
in äh und nicht und das ist nicht ich meine,
das ist leichter zugänglich für die Idee,
dass das Gehirn oder das kognitive
System weiß, dass
die Welt ist  so und so,
die Umwelt ist so und so, anstatt zu
sagen, dass das Agendasystem weiß, wie
man sich mit der Welt auseinandersetzt, und ich glaube,
der Punkt, den
Aktivisten und äh ökologische
Psychologen zu machen versuchen, ist,
die Vorhersage zu treffen und auch daran zu arbeiten
Codierung und das Prinzip der freien Energie
usw. soll zeigen, dass diese Begriffe dieser
Frameworks eine minimale Idee sein könnten, dass
das Kubernetes-System weiß, wie man
es einbindet, es weiß, wie man es einbindet  ge in
Umwelt so muss es
nicht gelesen werden,
dass das Kindle-System schlussfolgert,
dass die Welt so ist, also denke ich, dass dies
eine Art zu erklären ist, aber auch
philosophisch, wenn Sie einen großen
Anfang haben  die letzten
jahrzehnte äh eine gigantische diskussion darüber,
ob keine wolke reduziert werden könnte, um das zu
wissen und dann hast du wieder einen
hintergrund von diesem und anderem
als eigenständiger begriff von dir weiß
das und ob du
das eine auf das andere reduzieren könntest und so weiter
Ich denke, es hört hier nicht auf, Sie können nicht
, obwohl ich einen Anspruch auf Wahrnehmung erheben kann, da
einige andere wissen, dass
sie immer noch die Hintergrundfrage sind,
ob Know-how als behandelt werden könnte,
und das alles ist
sowieso etwas  Ich
arbeite auch in letzter Zeit daran, es
gibt viel zu sagen, es ist
eine so interessante Idee, besonders mit
sprachlicher Kommunikation, es ist ein
bisschen wie mit dem Finger und dem Mond und
über den Mond zu sprechen, aber der Finger ist
nur  wo es ist, und wir sprechen nicht
über den Zeiger, wir sprechen über
die Referenz,
und so
eine soziokognitive Form der Kommunikation
in kultivierter Sprache
oder im schriftlichen akademischen Diskurs zu verwenden, um das zu
durchschauen oder das neu zu erfinden und
sogar zu sehen, was scheint  wie der Pinnacle von zu sein, das
zu wissen
und es immer noch so zu sehen, wie
ich denke, die Frage ist,
wie lesen wir
Papiere?
ein sehr großes Problem, denn wenn
wir versuchen, diese negativen
Fähigkeiten, wie Sie es erwähnt haben, als eine Frage
des Know-hows zu behandeln
, scheint uns zum Beispiel immer noch etwas
an Kommunikation zu fehlen, und
andererseits denke ich, und das ist meine
Intuition, aber ich denke  dass wir im Prinzip darüber sprechen könnten, dass
das
Verständnis dessen, was Sie gerade gesagt haben, und der
Versuch, darauf zu antworten, eine Frage des
sprachlichen Verhaltens ist,
aber ich denke, dass selbst diese Bewegung
zur Behandlung hoher Ebenen von Kognitionswissenschaftlern,
die i  t eine Frage des Know-hows, es
lässt immer noch etwas aus, bei dem
ich bin, ich meine, ich persönlich bin
und damit zufrieden. Ich denke, auf einer gewissen
Ebene müssen wir sagen, dass das eine
andere Art von Ansatz ist, der hier benötigt wird
, um zu erklären, wie wir  Kommunizieren Sie zum
Beispiel
sehr angemessen, um nicht zu sagen, dass es
kein und jetzt beinhaltet, aber es ist nicht nur so,
dass ich denke, dass zumindest mehr als
praktisches Wissen erforderlich
ist, aber vielleicht ist der Schlüssel hier,
praktisches Wissen nur als grundlegend und
notwendig für andere Arten zu betrachten  von anderen anderen
Arten von Wissen, das sie brauchen,
um sich an dieser Art von Austausch zu beteiligen,
vielleicht vielleicht das vielleicht ist dies eine Ebene
Zumindest ist meine derzeitige Position, dass
kein Wie die Grundlage unserer
Auseinandersetzung mit der Welt und mit
anderen bildet, aber irgendwann müssen wir
in der Lage sein, andere Arten von
Verständnis zu entwickeln, um die komplexen Arten von äh zu erklären und zu erklären
Austausch, den
wir in unserem täglichen Leben haben,
wie das Lesen von Zeitungen, wie Sie gesagt haben.
Ich stimme zu, ich
denke, das Wissen als Grundlage zu definieren und dann das
Know-how wiederzugewinnen, ist eine Herausforderung, und
es ist auch eine Herausforderung, mit den
grundlegenden kognitiven Prozessen zu beginnen, da sie
ohne Haus durchgeführt werden  diese
Know-how-Teile wieder zusammenzusetzen, um zu wissen, dass dies
wiederum nicht unbedingt eine einfache
Herausforderung ist, sondern dass wir uns lieber der Herausforderung stellen würden,
symbolische,
propositionale, deklarative, verbale
usw. kognitive Prozesse aus einem
liminalen
ökologischen kognitiven Ansatz zusammenzusetzen
oder zu versuchen, das Ökologische aus
dem Turing wiederzugewinnen  Maschine in gewissem Sinne, also scheint es,
als ob
Sie zur Unterstützung der Erdung
in ökologisch plausiblen grundlegenden kognitiven
Prozessen sprechen und dann darauf
hinarbeiten, den Wolkenkratzer zusammenzubauen.
Ja, ja, total, ja
wie Sie gesagt haben, um
diese Art von Erklärung entweder
unten links oder von oben nach unten bereitzustellen, aber ich  Ich bin
natürlich für den Web-Ansatz günstiger.
Ich denke, es hat auch einen anderen
Grund, dass es scheint, als wäre der Ausgangspunkt
eine biologische Beschreibung dessen, wie wir
mit der Welt interagieren, und
umgekehrt scheint es viel
schwieriger zu sein  Um zu erklären, äh, wie wir
auf diese äh biologischen Fragen kommen,
wie unsere Körpermorphologie und so, scheint es,
dass wir das zuerst erklären müssen,
und dann kommen wir zu den anderen
Fragen, die auch schwer zu
beantworten sind, aber am Ende  Zumindest denke ich, dass
es
ein Bottom-up-Ansatz ist
, der in gewisser Weise integrativer ist, dass die Chancen
stehen, dass es
in dem Sinne mehr zu unseren Gunsten scheint,
und die Art und Weise, wie Sie es gerade formuliert
haben, hat mich denken lassen, dass Sie es wären
Um einen Computer von Grund auf neu zu programmieren, kann
es sich um einen abstrakten oder virtuellen
Computer handeln, sodass er nicht einmal
eine bestimmte Form haben muss,
und in diesem Fall muss man möglicherweise
wissen, was behauptet und
erklärt wird  ative
Aussagen und logische Prozesse in
etwas, das dynamischer ist oder
mit der Umgebung interagiert, aber
dieser Prozess wie Full-Stack-
Engineering
mit Logik und Silikon an der Basis
ist ganz anders als wir hierher gekommen sind,
und so könnte es sein, aber es ist
komplementär,
ähm  Sie haben ein wenig Einblick gegeben,
ähm, ich schätze, das Vorher, Während und
Nachher der Peer-Review, also war ich nur
neugierig, was
sich während und nach der Arbeit
in den letzten Monaten oder Jahren geändert hat oder wie
lange es auch war, wie haben Sie sich dabei entwickelt
und was dann  Sehen Sie die nächsten Schritte als relevant an
, ob sie für Sie oder
nur allgemein zu tun sind? Suchen wir
nach einer Gehirnmessung? Suchen wir
nach einer Videokamera in einem Wald?
Suchen wir nach einem konzeptionellen
Fortschritt?  Ihre
Entwicklungen
, das ist eine großartige Frage. Ich denke,
ähm,
ich bin nicht ganz zufrieden mit der
Art und Weise, wie ich fremdes Niveau verwende
t in äh Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht,
ob man das grundsätzlich auch in
anderen empirischen Begriffen durchführen könnte, aber
äh ich sage nicht, dass
äh na ja, ich würde es
heute etwas anders schreiben nicht, dass es äh nicht so ist,
dass ich dem nicht zustimme  Papier
ursprünglich, aber ich denke, es
gibt einige Punkte, die ich
gerne umformulieren würde, aber sie
autorisieren auch nicht, äh, ich denke, er hatte ein neues
Papier,
aber vielleicht in der Zukunft, aber das ist
etwas,
das die Fragen wie der Mythos
gegeben haben  immer noch die philosophische
Frage
und die konzeptionelle, sie stören
mich immer noch, aber ich muss
noch die Gelegenheit finden, diese Ideen sorgfältiger zu entwickeln,
und die allgemeine
Sichtweise, die ich dort darlege, denke ich, ich denke,
sie steht immer noch,
aber
ähm,
ich möchte, dass ich ich  Ich warte immer noch auf
diese Chance, es weiter auszuarbeiten und zu
sehen, wie weit ich komme, aber ich weiß es noch
nicht. Ich muss zugeben, ich weiß nicht, was
die zukünftigen Entwicklungen dieser Idee sind,
aber ähm, ich habe gearbeitet  zu mehreren
Einzelproblemen  An diesem Ansatz
habe ich in den letzten Jahren mit
dem Begriff der Information und des wissenschaftlichen
Verständnisses und
der Kombination von Informationen für Umwelt- und Aktivisten gearbeitet,
und in letzter Zeit arbeite ich
mit einigen Hochschulen an
virtueller Realität und Wahrnehmungserkennung,
also
ähm  So führe ich meine Recherchen gerne durch,
um interessante Fragen zu finden
und zu sehen, wie ich
mit ihnen umgehen kann, aber nicht unbedingt auf
diese Weise an eine einzige Argumentationslinie
gebunden
bin  Rationalität, wenn ich dachte, es
wäre ein sehr cooles Thema, und äh, ich
denke immer noch, aber ich hatte nicht die Zeit
, zurückzukommen und neu zu formulieren, was ich wollte
, aber äh, vielleicht vielleicht irgendwann in
naher Zukunft, ich weiß nicht, aber mehr  Die
neueste Sache, an der ich gearbeitet habe,
hat nichts mit zellulärer
Rationalität zu tun, aber ich denke, einige Produkte
könnten falsch sein, nämlich die einer
virtuellen Realität und
wie vergleicht sich die visuelle Realität tatsächlich
mit com  Bination,
weil es offensichtlich etwas
an Ausdauer und an einer visuellen
Umgebung fehlt,
ähm, natürlich, wenn ich jemanden zum
Beispiel befinde, wenn ich mich in einer visuellen
Umgebung befinde, in der ich einer Art
Bedrohung ausgesetzt bin, fühle ich vielleicht etwas Analoges zu
Angst, aber  Ich fürchte nicht wirklich um mein
Leben
und stelle mir vor, dass die Person in der
virtuellen Realität so vernünftig ist,
vor
der Bedrohung, der virtuellen Bedrohung und
so weiter wegzulaufen. Das ist das das das ist das,
woran ich arbeite  weiter und ähm, vielleicht ist es
ein Punkt, um zu
dieser Idee der radikalen und aktiven
Rationalität zurückzukehren, und tatsächlich, ähm, das Papier wurde
gerade angenommen, also war ich, wie
ich Ihnen vorher sagte, in den letzten Tagen so beschäftigt,
weil wir meine Beweise korrigierten
Kollegen und ich nie im übertragenen Sinne
äh und ich Ich hatte
auch einen engen Zeitplan
, um die korrigierte Version der
Arbeit in den letzten Wochen einzureichen, und dann
bekam ich die Korrekturabzüge und
oh
äh, vielleicht äh, in der Zukunft kann
ich wieder zum iss kommen  ue der Rationalität
würde ich gerne, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich ich
weiß nicht ich kann die Entwicklung davon wirklich nicht vorhersehen
, aber äh im Allgemeinen
stimme ich immer noch mit meiner ursprünglichen Idee überein, aber
ich werde es ein wenig anders formulieren  Bisschen
also der VR-Punkt Ich bin mir sicher, dass es dort noch
viel mehr zu sagen gibt, aber es erinnerte
mich nur an den Titel Virtual Reality, es ist eine
Virtualisierung, und so
ermöglicht uns die kognitive Aktionsplanung,
Richtlinien zu verfolgen, die unser Körper nicht tut.  Es reicht nicht aus, sie
zu bewerten und sich
dagegen zu entscheiden, aber wir können einen
Höhenflug machen und einen skurrilen Politikauswahlprozess
kontrafaktischer Aussagen durchführen,
aber dann ist unsere Morphologie so etwas wie
unsere Rettungsleine, wissen Sie, wenn Sie tatsächlich
von einem Felsvorsprung fallen, dann ist es so  zu schmerzen
und dann ist deine verkörperte Wahrnehmungserfahrung in der virtuellen Realität
buchstäblich
eine Virtualisierung
überlebenskritischer Situationen, so dass du
dich vielleicht auf einem Felsvorsprung
siehst, aber du bist auf einem flachen Boden
und dann in dieser Situation
Wenn Sie
außerhalb des Videospiels eine Art kognitiver Beobachter
sind, könnten Sie sagen, dass es
für mich rational ist, einfach herunterzufallen, um zu sehen,
was passiert  im Spiel,
ähm, es verwischt irgendwie die Grenze
zwischen
[Musik]
, es verwischt die Kritikalität
des Körpers und ähm,
ich bin sicher, Sie haben viel
mehr darüber nachgedacht, also wie spielt sich das in unsere
virtuelle Realität ein,
ähm mit dem  Wie wir über diese Systeme nachdenken und sie verwenden
und gestalten,
das sind die
Fragen, die uns dazu motiviert haben, eine Arbeit zu schreiben
, und äh, NADA, die ich ihnen gegeben habe, und ich war,
dass in der Fachliteratur zu sehen ist,
dass viele Forscher damit
arbeiten  äh behandle äh visuelle Wahrnehmung als
illustri eine Art Illusion, aber das hat uns
ein bisschen gestört, weil
es andererseits nur in VR funktioniert, weil
wir wir die Geräte Geräte verkörpert haben, die
für uns arbeiten, du hast die Controller, du
hast den Kopf  gesetzt
und äh, es scheint so seltsam zu sagen, dass der
Benutzer der Benutzer unter einer Art
Illusion steht,
und andererseits scheint es, dass es
nicht wirklich Kognition ist, denn wie Sie
sagten, gibt es keine biologische
äh Relevanz für diese äh kognitiven
Sagt sozusagen, wenn ich
einen Apfel in VR sehe, ist er nicht
nahrhaft, aber im Spiel sinnvoll,
aber anders, ähm,
gut, ich habe einen Apfel in einer
realen Umgebung gesehen, ist er
nahrhaft  Es ist etwas, das ich essen kann,
aber in VR kann ich nicht vorgeben, also haben wir
dieses äh Konzept der Anspielung auf
seine Ebene geprägt
In die Irre geführt zu werden, weil wir die Ausrüstung anziehen, von der
wir wissen, dass wir im Spiel sind,
und ich denke, dass dies im Moment ein heißes Thema ist,
weil es Metaphern gibt und ich sehr skeptisch bin,
was
die Leute angeht, sind die Leute sehr optimistisch, aber
was die Möglichkeiten der Metave angeht  rse
und einige Autoren denken wirklich, dass
wir streng genommen in einer Simulation sein könnten,
aber ich meine, die beste
Technologie, die uns die aktuelle Technologie zeigt
, ist, dass sie sehr begrenzt ist und man so
tun kann, als wäre man in einer bestimmten Umgebung
und so weiter, und das denke ich  kann
eine neue
Denkweise bieten, über Rationalität in dieser
visuellen Umgebung nachzudenken, in einer Weise, dass
Russen vielleicht etwas tun, was die
Umgebung gesagt hat, um von der Kante zu springen und zu sehen,
was passiert, und andererseits
Verhaltensaspekte, die die Menschen dabei manchmal
tatsächlich fühlen  Angst und Menschen
stehen wegen Phobien mit virtuellen Realitäten auf der Straße
und
ähm, es gibt viele
interessante Fragen, die
ich vielleicht für zukünftige Forschungen meine, wir können
ja darauf zurückkommen. Es hat mich zum Nachdenken gebracht,
wie Apple es im wirklichen Leben tut  könnten
Kalorien für dich sein, aber auch
Kalorien für eine Fliege, sie könnte geworfen werden,
du könntest sie als Hammer benutzen, du könntest
sie richtig malen, also
Ökologie und Generativ  Prozess, wie
wir sagen würden, eine aktive
Inferenz geht immer über die
für ein bestimmtes Objekt programmierten Erschwinglichkeiten hinaus, und außerdem konzentriert sich
der aktuelle Diskurs über VR
stark auf Headsets,
nur anekdotisch gesagt,
nicht mein Fachgebiet,
ähm, es scheint a  Ein bisschen interessant,
es ist, als ob sich die
Mobiltelefondiskussion nur auf
Rechtecke einer bestimmten Größe konzentrierte,
was dies nicht zur virtuellen Realität macht, es ist,
als würde man durch ein Fenster schauen und es
gibt einen anderen Kerl, mit dem man sprechen kann, also
hängt es nicht an meinem Kopf, das tut es nicht
haben einige der Bewegungsverfolgungskapazitäten
, die einige Technologien
haben, aber es ist
eine Nischenmodifikation im persönlichen
Raum von Perry,
und wir können
Signale und Angebote aneinander senden,
so dass wir eine VR-Framing oder wirklich nur eine
Rationalitäts- und Wahrnehmungs-
Kognitions-Aktionszyklen-Framing
haben
sind nicht nur auf eine bestimmte
Realisierung oder einen bestimmten Hardwaretyp beschränkt und können
die Bandbreite von Total Offline
Person in a Field
bis hin zu s abdecken  Jemand, der sehr
in The Matrix ist,
scheint ziemlich relevant zu sein, ansonsten werden neue
Technologien, selbst kleine Varianten und
Software-Updates, weiterhin
unendlich überraschen und verwirren.
Ja, ich denke, es ist schwer,
die Grenzen zu definieren.
Ich meine, wir sind hier in einem
Austausch  Ich denke, es könnte zunehmen, aber
als eine Form der virtuellen Realität eingestuft werden.
Natürlich sehe ich, dass Sie Ihren C-
Geist ruinieren, aber
äh, ich meine, die meisten, denke ich, funktionieren, dass
sie heutzutage finden, dass sie es als Dokumentarfilm bezeichnen, indem sie
sagen, dass sie ein Headset haben müssen  und
manchmal ein Controller, aber ansonsten
klingt es nach Virtual Reality, aber
ja, es ist schwer, etwas zu definieren, äh,
es ist nicht, es ist kein Müll und
einfach, das ist eines der Dinge,
denn wenn man kaufmännisch spricht,
bedeutet Virtual Reality natürlich Headsets
und andere Utensilien, aber aber  Ein
Telefon, das einfach telefoniert, oder ein
Telegraf, in dieser Zeit wäre
es an dieser Schnittstelle mit dieser sensorischen
Modalität und mit diesen Angeboten gewesen, die es
ist  Die Virtualisierung,
ja, zu der wir heute Zugang haben, ist ein
anderes Kapitel,
ja, ich denke, ja, ein Teil unserer Arbeit
war zu argumentieren, dass die Verkörperung technologischer Geräte in gewisser Weise
offensichtlich notwendig ist, nicht das ist nicht neu, es ist das
Zeichen des
Menschseins  technologische Geräte zu verkörpern,
was uns von Anfang an zu dem gemacht hat, was wir sind
, indem wir analytische Technologie verwenden, und die Tatsache, dass wir
ein Gerät so kompetent verkörpern können, selbst wenn es
zum Beispiel darauf programmiert ist, in der
virtuellen Realität etwas zu haben, mit dem Sie eine
Kreatur haben, mit der Sie uns steuern reicher  neue
Morphologie eine andere Morphologie zum
Beispiel, auch wenn das der Fall ist, es
passiert nur so kompetent, weil wir in der
Lage sind, das Gerät zu verkörpern. Einige
Experimente haben gezeigt, dass Sie
zum Beispiel eine Drehung Ihres Handgelenks auf einen
dritten Arm
abbilden können, äh, von dem die individuelle Realität ausgeht
das von Ihrer Brust aus und die Leute können
lernen, diesen dritten Arm zu kontrollieren,
der nicht in unsere tatsächliche Morphologie passt,
aber durch einen Twist o so gemacht werden kann
Wenn wir das Handgelenk besprechen, werden wir das in unserem Artikel besprechen. Das
können Sie nur, weil Sie
das Gerät verkörpern. Sie können sehen, dass es eine
Illusion ist
würde so gehen Ich meine, ich weiß, dass es
die Unterscheidung zwischen virtuellen
und nicht-virtuellen Knospen verwischt Ich denke, das ist eine
Möglichkeit, mit dieser
coolen Sache umzugehen. Gibt es noch etwas, worüber Sie
sprechen möchten
?  Ich möchte Ihnen für die
Gelegenheit danken, dieses Papier zu diskutieren. Es war
sehr schön für mich. Ich habe es wirklich genossen.
Dies ist eine äh, sehr schöne und äh,
angenehme Umgebung, um diese
Themen zu diskutieren  wir kommen
jederzeit gerne wieder mit dir in ordnung
okay danke auf wiedersehen danke